i have an unbelievable video to play for
you a former national security adviser
john bolton going on newsmax
and triggering newsmax host eric balling
newsmax is furious
with bolton
bolton is not a good guy and if anybody
is going to plan to write to me today
and say david you're rehabilitating john
bolton's image
you are praising a war criminal i am not
praising john bolton
the thing about john bolton is he's a
horrible warmongering disgusting neocon
who rightly has assessed that trump is a
lunatic and trump is dangerous and on
that particular issue
he happens to be correct and the degree
to which he triggers eric balling is
unbelievable john bolton has been
correctly saying
we are safer under biden than under
trump
doesn't mean bolton's a democrat doesn't
mean i like bolton doesn't mean he's a
good guy doesn't mean he wasn't one of
the architects of the iraq war it just
means he has correctly assessed that we
are more safe under biden than trump
because trump's completely unhinged
this so triggered eric balling you have
to see this oral could you think that
we're safer now than we were under
president trump when he was willing to
put missiles into syrian air bases with
russians on the base what's going on
here sir he didn't understand because he
didn't understand fundamentally much of
anything about international affairs
true his decisions were not based on a
coherent philosophy well
they weren't based on a coherent foreign
policy philosophy they were based on the
philosophy of
what can i do or say right now that will
benefit me
that that was the to in that sense trump
was adhering to a philosophy he often
miscalculated and it was a depraved
philosophy but bolton's essentially
correct more coherent powers
under donald trump
world leaders he signed a deal with the
taliban he kept them on their back feet
didn't know where he was coming from and
that made us say now there's a moment
here where bolton belly laughs at
balling and that really sends balling
into a tailspin i mean can you he had
president
deal with the taliban
you know what made us less safe is when
biden pulled us out of afghanistan 13
americans died and now this trump stands
so
even bolton trump's national security
adviser says
what biden did in afghanistan was the
exact same thing trump was going to do
you're hearing it from the horse's mouth
and the trump is still denied they go no
it would have gone so smoothly if it had
been trump overseeing that withdrawal no
it wouldn't have tells us back off don't
kill al-qaeda
are you out of your mind same thing they
would have done under donald trump sir
are you out of your mind with respect of
course no oh who who cut the deal eric
who cut the deal who delivered the deal
no no no trump wanted to what would
trump have done
no he did not he absolutely did not he
did eric you don't know what you're
talking about
everybody out here
to do exactly that disagrees with you we
don't know what we're talking about
trump said leave twenty five hundred
there until we have a smooth trade he
did not
he
look he said that after he cut the deal
the deal cut us down to zero that's what
trump wanted he wanted everybody out the
record on that is completely clear over
time biden pulled them out well with
americans still there the best read the
deal eric have you ever read the deal
i'll stop it yeah i know you gotta go
before you're embarrassed even further
okay so listen i really don't like john
bolton but that was very good it really
takes some skill
to make bolton seem like the rational
one in the room or the rational one in
the conversation and again don't write
to me that i'm praising bolton bolton is
a warmongering neoconservative hack but
he specifically pressed some important
points number one
what biden did was the deal trump made
and number two
it wouldn't have gone any differently if
it had been trump doing the pull-out and
yes of course we are generally speaking
safer under joe biden merely because joe
biden is a steadier hand and the best
part is bolton just laughing at him and
saying you don't know what you're
talking about sending balling off
completely off the rails
at least there are people willing to say
this who are from the former maggot camp
and you know when it comes to bolton
did he know that trump was a lunatic all
along but he was so hungry for the power
of being national security adviser that
he looked the other way
did he believe trump was rational but
then had an awakening i don't even care
i think all of these people are terrible
people whatever brought them to this
point it doesn't even really matter but
anything that can pierce the echo
chamber of a platform as weaponized as
newsmax i think we generally speaking
need to welcome
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 percent made from bamboo a
bamboo stock keeps growing it can be
harvested forever it means that the soil
and the ecosystem aren't disrupted no
carbon removing trees are cut down the
paper industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
soft toilet paper real paper loves the
david pakman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below